manger du chocolat
l'objectif est clair ce samedi 16 avril
à la ferme de gally de saint-cyr-l'ecole
trouver du chocolat pour cela ces jeunes
explorateurs sillonnent les champs du
site pour amasser des fosses de colorer
leur collecte est ensuite échangé avec
de vrais gourmandise on a une petite
règle du jeu on attend duff jaune à
trouver blanc bleu etc on donne une
petite boîte tough aux enfants ils
remplissent leurs petits oeufs et sinon
la nouveauté de cette année c'est qu'on
a caché 5,9 d'or dans la ferme mais moi
je suis pas au courant ou ses cachets et
ceux qui trouvent ils auront une petite
surprise au moment de notre tournage un
seul oeuf d'or avait été trouvé mais les
enfants ont tous gagné leur boîte au
total près de 6000 paniers ont été
distribués sur deux jours à l'occasion
de cette fête d eux on retrouve à chaque
fois doux chocolat est parfois plus à
l'intérieur est ce que tu en penses quoi
de cette journée
marquée elle a déjà passé
il fait beau on est bien la ferme de
gally fidèle à elle même et on fait
plaisir à notre enfant aujourd'hui c'est
super c'est vraiment sympa pour les
enfants cette chasse aux oeufs colorés
en parallèle de cette chasse les
visiteurs pouvaient participer à
différents ateliers créatifs autour de
la ferme des oeufs de la laine ou encore
de la nature pour respirent tous
ensemble dehors qu'on apprenne qu'on
joue qu'on soit ensemble on partage
voilà des moments simples on partage
ensemble et que tous les sens sont en
éveil à travers nos animaux les couleurs
des prêts qu'ils changent et les yeux de
couleur etc une journée pour se
construire de beaux souvenirs en famille
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition de la fête des oeufs à
la ferme de gally